السيد عمر فاروق هذا بالشكل انا صعيد
المضمون ما الرسائل التي ارادها الرئيس
اردوغان من كلمته من شرفه القصر الرئاسي
وقال بانه سيتوجه بهذه الكلمه للعالم وليس
فقط
للاتراك ما ابرز ما لفتك فيها واولا كان
يقول قبل الانتخابات ان نتيجه هذه
الانتخابات ستؤدي الى ربح للجميع لن يخسر
احد في بعد هذه الانتخابات اذا هو فازه
وكرر هذه الكلمه ان شعب التركي الذين
صوتوا ولم يصوت له الجميل سيربح لن يخسر
احد هذه الملاحظه الاولى النقطه الثانيه
هو اشار الى نقطه مهمه جدا ان هناك بعض
المراكز غربيه خاصه فرنسيه المانيه او
الانجليزيه خاصه بعض المجلات الاساسيه في
هذه البلدان كانت تستهدف اردوغان في هذا
في هذا الانتخابات هو قال ان كلهم هزموا
امام اراده الشعب التركي هذه النقطه ايضا
مهمه جدا نقطه اخرى وارسل رسائل الى الى
الاستقاء خاصه في العالم الذين يعني
يحبون شعب التركي او النمو الاقتصاد
التركي بان التركيه القويه سوف تكون لصالح
للجميع ليس مضره لاحد وبالتالي القرن
التركيه ستكون مصلحه للجميع ايضا الدول
التي تتحالف مع التركيه اقتصاديا وتتعاون
مع تركيا كلهم سوف يربحون ويستفيدون ثانيا
يبدا اردوغان لديه توجه جديد في اقتصال
التركي لانه
ركز على الاقتصاد التركي كثيرا وقال ان
تركيا اخرجت غاز في في بحر الاسود البحر
الاسود واخرج ايضا البترول في جنوب شرق
التركيه لان التركيه طردت الارهاب من هذه
المناطق وبالتالي تركيا القادمه ستكون
مزدهر اكثر يعني في استقرار اكثر بسبب هذا
الازدهار الاقتصادي